all right they are going to have fans in
buffalo on saturday when the playoffs
get started 6 700 of them will get to
finally
witness their team which has been
phenomenal this year and better and
better and better each and every week
they are blowing teams out they have
that glow of a special team of a team of
destiny that's what it feels like for
the buffalo bills right now and josh i'm
telling you chris i know that aaron
rodgers is your guy
but i know that josh allen's your guy
too yeah
and i i i
i really do believe that the mvp
question yeah between i hear aaron
rodgers and josh allen is a lot closer
than than
95 of the people would acknowledge i
listen i agree with you there i think it
is much closer than people realize at
least in in my eyes i mean you know
again i don't know i think through the
year
really if we broke it down from wows and
wow factor i don't think anybody made a
say wow more every week than josh allen
i think that's just the honest to god
truth you and i sitting there i know
you're in west virginia but we can see
each other you see our room i don't
think there's a quarterback in football
this year that made us say wow whoa
unbelievable all of that there was that
two-week span i know where they lost to
the titans of chiefs other than that
it's been you know to what you're saying
big time mvp type football and yesterday
like mike you're right they got a glow
they got a confidence about them you
know there there it is it's 21-6 and
matt barkley it's 21-3 let's just unpack
it a little bit
and tua and the dolphins go down to get
a field goal then 21-6 and then
meanwhile matt barkley is warming up the
whole time and you're going oh that's it
the bills are going to do it i don't
know mcdermott didn't like that it was
21-6 or whatever he wanted to put them
away for real they josh allen runs out
there they go down and score a touchdown
they're just they kind of seem like an
unstoppable force right now with what
they're doing on that side of the ball
it's really fun to watch miami came in
yesterday with the number one scoring
defense in the nfl
and they got absolutely obliterated to
where the bills could have scored 70
something if they wanted and then that
just tells you the way the bills are
playing football right now
yeah i haven't crunched the numbers i
have a feeling giving up 56 in the final
game of the season will take a chunk out
of that uh that standing is the number
one scoring defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports